you are the news right cats make you
crazy and not just because they act coy
or trip you when you're walking because
they're hungry or act like they want you
to scratch the bellies and then bite you
know we're talking real mental illness
there's this bacterium called Toxoplasma
gondii that's commonly found in cat poop
and the theory is that exposure to this
bacterium at a young age can lead to
mental illness surveys show that people
with schizophrenia were exposed to cats
as adolescents about 10 percent more
often than those without schizophrenia
although that 10 percent difference is
kind of significant it's not conclusive
but it raises an interesting question is
a bacterial infection partly responsible
for causing mental illness that would be
crazy
so why hasn't it been tested well
because to do it right
you'd have to expose a number of
children to a bacterial infection in
short ethics so all we can really do is
rely on these surveys and other indirect
studies and while your cat can
definitely make you crazy in any number
of ways the jury's still out on whether
any of them are actual mental
you